all right y'all you know how we do let's
get it in
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
to your oh [__] what happened
do your favorite podcast
real feelings
[Music]
okay I fumbled the start whatever
welcome back to River with Griffin today
I'm gonna finally talk about the SAG
strike talk about my thoughts
why I think it's happening why I think
it happened where it's gonna go I love
this I love 90 Day Fiance and there's
this one
before the 90 days these cast of
characters are just it's crazy and of
course other news and notes around the
world but welcome back
foreign
[Music]
you know I gotta warn my voice up before
I just come on here you know what I mean
I gotta get my [__] together anyways
welcome to Roofing with Griffin your
favorite podcast what's it all about you
know uh riff with Griff sometimes it's a
comment sometimes it's comedy sometimes
it's serious but it's always
authentically a hundred percent me thank
you for new people that have never come
before I appreciate you and all the uh
the loyal followers I appreciate you
guys as always so what you might want to
do is
hit that subscribe button subscribe
[Music]
um and then I'm on Twitch
you can follow me on Twitch Eric Griffin
gaming I game all the time I love it I
have a lot of really loyal fans there
we've been going strong since the
pandemic so you can be a subscriber and
if you want to support the show you
could be a YouTube member you could be a
twitch subscriber or you could join the
patreon which any one of those ways you
want to help financially support the
show I appreciate
that greatly and upcoming this weekend
y'all make sure you guys check me out at
I will be at the Jacksonville
Comedy Zone so come check me out in
Jacksonville this weekend September 7th
through the night
go to Eric griffin.com for tickets to go
to the Jacksonville Comedy Zone website
I'll see you Florida come and check me
out
[Music]
all right anyways
um welcome back to riffing with Griffin
y'all what's going on this week first I
want to thank our sponsors of this show
I want to thank doordash go to doordash
and put in code rwg for riffing with
Griffin shop doordash to get everything
you need for back to school season
delivered right to your door that's and
you're gonna get 50 off up to ten dollar
value and you spend 15 or more promo
code riffing with Griffin terms and
conditions apply thank you doordash
um all right so guys welcome back to
River with Griffin we are here we are
doing what we do as always
what's going on this week uh you know I
am going to Jacksonville so I'm looking
forward to that pregnancy is coming
along great excited you know what I'm
really looking forward to I can't wait
to get my my kid a Captain America shirt
so we can go out you know father sign
Captain Americas
the little things you're looking for you
know what I don't understand about like
you know you have all these pregnancy
apps that'll help you like you know Day
Day 130 of the pregnancy and then it
tells you like your baby is the size of
a of of a apple you know every date is
like a new fruit and at first I thought
it was like to scale and I'd be like oh
okay this is pretty cool you know it
starts as a line so you think they would
go like this it should go lime lemon
Orange grapefruit that seems like the
progression but this sucker's all over
the place so one week it was
like a sweet potato okay
sweet potatoes like what size sweet
potatoes sweet potatoes are big because
I just bought some sweet potatoes I'm
suckers is huge and then it was uh and
then it went to us then it was like a
banana I was like wait hold on a second
a banana ain't bringing in a sweet
potato what we talking about here we're
talking about length with girth what are
we talking about so I just I don't
understand the fruit thing
you know it's just like can we it needs
to be like a more consistent track you
know like somebody understand you know
when it goes it's a pea it's a it's a
cherry you know it's a strawberry you
know that seems to be like okay well
it's getting bigger all right but when
they start doing this like sweet potato
baked potato uh banana now I'm like okay
y'all just messing with me now this
ain't real so you know I don't know you
parents out there how did you how did
you keep track and uh what was it you
know
for me right now I I can't I cannot keep
track I don't know what's happening with
this
um
yeah so that's nothing more to report
you know Rachel gets sick some days and
some days she's great you know but one
thing is she has to eat she's not
feeling well uh it's I know then now we
know it's like we gotta get some food in
her because then she eats and then right
away she's like oh I feel a lot better
you know and then she's ready to go do
stuff you know so it's um
you know she hasn't been going to work
and so now it's like she's about to go
start that again and then decide if she
wants to do it or not you know it's one
of those things you know you just have
to see how you feel you know not
everybody's in the position she is to
like she could just go see if she could
do it if she can't then that's gonna be
the rap that's a wrap on that but you
know it you know it's it's just it's
just one of those things I think it's
like I think it's like good to stay busy
and moving and all that kind of stuff
yeah so I don't know and then I'm trying
to start my workout Journey which is
like
man it's tough
I don't know why why it's like so easy
just to not do it right it's just easy
just to like even if you try to like
okay I'm not gonna eat as much I'm gonna
like but there it's like yes diet is
super important the most important part
about keeping maintaining your health
and weight but then the exercise part is
important for heart health and all that
kind of stuff and it's just so easy just
to be like I don't want to do it
so I don't know I'm really trying to
challenge myself because I just want to
be
I just I want to be in better shape man
I just do
I don't know so somebody said in the
chat the fruit thing is mainly so you
could take a photo of that fruit in
front of the belly to track their size I
mean but it's like
I believe it it just it just seems like
it's all nonsense but since we're doing
that let's go to the comments guys it's
comment time and if you have a comment I
have the uh the the Q a up but this time
I did it early so you don't see me
typing it but even though I'm talking
about it so it's even worse so the
comments you know you want to be a part
of the show you write a comment on the
um the thing I actually should go look
at the the Apple comments too sometimes
but please you know actually it helps
when you comment and give good reviews
there you know give me some good stars
there and review that helps the
algorithm when more people listen to the
podcast so I appreciate that
um all right so
let's see comments this week uh I hate
when people don't have a real name you
know when people just have a dumb name
you know it's like if if your name is
username like you're worthless
make an effort man make an effort
all right so we got nibbles
nibbles stupid name Dot biscuits4270.
I hate you all can't believe I didn't
see this earlier good energy from Eric
sub and looking forward to watching more
so I appreciate that I like reading
those because it's like you know
you know I love them new people come to
the podcast I hate when people don't
spell my name right though and this is
one of those user whatever I'm not even
gonna read it forget it oh
um so then I you know I put up a post
about that uh you know the guy that had
sex with the cow and then somebody then
uh our
roh hypnotist
hypnotic hypnotist he had six two six
three the rule don't play with your food
applies here
funny
give you a little star there I like that
um
uh ninja Jake I listened to this episode
on Spotify laughed out loud when you
said cow cow style instead of doggy
style yeah the cow thing was funny to me
I don't know and then the seaweed guide
uh no I had a good one ready to go
um yeah so you know if you want to write
a comment I'll look look for it so this
guy Marlin's Stallings 5229 said Eric I
challenge you to a hundred incline
push-ups a day for the whole month of
September
okay all right thank you
I'll consider it
incline push-ups what are those are like
ones that are on like it's not like
direct push-ups like you're on the
stairs or something like that is that
what that is
I don't know
um then there's a guy 93 TJ fresh he
goes I don't trust AI
it's a common thing just excuse me
that's actually a common feeling I think
people have but I say don't be old I
think AI is something that we're gonna
have to embrace I think it's gonna it's
gonna change our world it already has it
actually already has been used it's we
we just now realizing that what it is
man it's just changed our world man it's
changed our world use it as a tool it's
a tool man all search engines are going
to be Ai and they're just it's better in
my opinion because of the follow-up
questions so but I get it I get why you
don't trust AI
Trey smith2490 I watched Champion a
couple months ago I believe on peacock
literally one of the most best movies
made in a long time that's the kind of
movie we need right now you know what
I'm going to tell you and I didn't talk
about this last week so if you if you
never if you haven't watched Champions
it's with Woody Harrelson it's about
this like uh like
basketball coach he's an assistant but
he's got a like a Gruff attitude he gets
into a DUI he gets a DUI and the judge
sentences him to work with these um
special needs kids to coach them at like
a community center he has to coach them
for like 90 days and you could just
guess what happens you know what I mean
but the thing that I like about it is
it's like yes you have this movie and
the stars of the movie
are people
with disabilities Down syndrome whatever
they they belong in this movie because
the movie's about them you know what I
mean and their stories and they all have
like different stories and it's great
this ain't this kind of like stuff where
you go you have like a movie and then
you make a character
you make a character different to like
appease the people out there who think
they're good people because they watch
this no every every Walk of Life
deserves to have a story told
and you don't have to change the story
or you know what I mean it's like
uh it's delicate but I just think make
more movies like this you know make more
movies you know it's like
just make more movies for everyone
you know and then you just watch it if
you want to watch it you know it's like
do you tell everyone's Story Just
because you don't relate to the person
in the story doesn't mean you it's not a
valuable story
you know just make good stories that's
all have some Artistic integrity make
good stories
it's like anytime I can feel the
diversity meeting you know and that's
mostly Disney right now it's like it's
just like what are you doing man just
make this story if this is mid-century
white family then it's okay that they're
all white that's okay everybody in this
movie is white it's fine it's fine okay
I don't know it's just that I just go
watch Champions is the point I'm on a
rant it I'm not even making sense to
myself
um let's see what we got here
let's see
um
wait there was a comment I wanted to
read I wanted to get the person's name
because he you know
he he like called me out on something
and it was just really funny because I
did say it wrong anyway I was doing my
football reviews last week and so the
the
I believe that the running back from the
Jets his name is Bruce Holmes I think
that's his name right and I said priest
Holmes last week which is like an old
school Chiefs running back so the guy
was like calling me out like man you
made me laugh and then when I think
about it it makes me laugh too I don't
even know if I even said the game the
guy's name right now but I was in a Jets
fan who follows the Jets the only reason
why I even following the Jets now is
because
um we're following it just because
freaking
Patrick Mahomes is there right
and then we have somebody says somebody
needs to count already read that comment
that's the comment from last week but
anyways thanks for the comments guys uh
you know be a part of the show write a
comment and we'll see what happens there
so I I appreciate uh all that energy you
know what let me pop out to chat so I
can uh I don't know wait no I'm gonna
leave it there it is what it is all
right I'm just real quick here I'll go
to let me go to the Q a section see if
anybody has put any questions in yes
they have I just became a big sister
with bbbs any advice from a grown ass
man I don't even know
what I don't even know what that is
I got to Google that
we'll get back to that one uh
um have you watched righteous gemstones
no I you know it's not I haven't watched
it because for any like reason it's just
there's so many shows on the air it's
like I always say shows are like
relationships and I'm not trying to get
into another relationship just yet
um
let's see talk to me yet I'd love to
hear your thoughts on that movie I
haven't seen that movie yet just and
I'll I don't know I'm gonna see some
movies this weekend when I'm in
Jacksonville
um
uh I don't even know what that one is
somebody said unknown person Nicki Minaj
and cod
so you know
Call of Duty they always like license
people's likenesses and then you'll have
that character in the game so right now
you could play as Nicki Minaj in Call of
Duty and she's got like a pink outfit
with a big ass booty
big ass booty okay it's like okay they
got 21 Savage they got Snoop Dogg they
got Kevin Durant you could you know you
buy these blueprints for these players
and that always works the store on Call
of Duty always works
the game oh there's always some nonsense
but the store you can count on the store
all right anyways so
yeah we're back you know what
this is a good time to this is a good
time just to go right into our sponsor
door Dash guys doordash I want to thank
them I want to thank door Josh for being
a sponsor
um first of all right now back to school
is here something I'm gonna have to look
forward to in coming years and you could
you know you could cross everything off
your list by going right to doordash
anything you forgot to get you get from
doordash you know it's not just food
it's not just picking up stuff from a
restaurant now you can order things that
you need you're looking for a gold star
get it all back to school hack the first
day back is almost here
and so are the long list of Essentials
your kids need for class with doordash
you can find everything you need all in
one place
obviously I love getting doordash
because you know you get everything you
need actually I just ordered like a ream
of paper you know that's the kind of
things you need you need like you know
printer ink whatever there's certain
stores you can order from it's right
there on doordash I love doordash I use
it you should use it to use code rwg
that's riffing with Griffin shop
doordastic and everything you need for
back to school season delivered right to
your door order now for stress free back
to school shopping use promo code rwg to
get 50 off up to 10 value when you spend
15 or more at convenience grocery or
retail stores on doordash that's fifty
percent off up to ten dollar value when
you spend 15 or more promo code rwg
terms and conditions apply
okay guys let's get into some uh
let's get into some stuff
all right so one of the things I wanted
to get into
um let's go to this uh I don't know if
you guys watch 90 Day Fiance do you get
I don't know if you're watching 90 Day
Fiance I I love 90 Day Fiance I don't
know if you know the concept of 90 Day
Fiance but it's simple so you have like
these people who met they don't live in
the same country they have this like
Whirlwind romance and one of them wants
to move to the United States and the
only way you can move is you have to get
a work visa or you have to get a
marriage visa and you have 90 days to do
that that's why they call the 90 Day
Fiance that was the original show
so they follow these people and it's
always like now the first few seasons
most of the couple's weird as hell right
and it's like the kind of couple where
it's like fat guy really good looking
woman from another country or vice versa
fat girl really good slim looking guy
and then you kind of go okay what is
this and then occasionally they'll have
like that couple that you feel like okay
they look like they just they belong
together but then there's some other
drama with it and then what they started
to do they made like 90 Day Fiance after
the 90 days before the 90 days uh you
know they had this one right now uh 90
Day Fiance The Last Resort and it's
about like these Couples from all these
shows and how they're trying to work out
their troubles at a resort right so it's
like the last resort it's at a resort
then there's like counseling and couples
therapy and all this stuff and it's just
so fascinating this is one of the most
more fascinating reality TV series that
you can watch just watching crazy people
be crazy but this one is something else
this 90 day you know I'd say so this one
is so first they had nowadays fiance and
there's usually someone from a foreign
country and they're moving to the United
States okay that was 90 days the other
way that one's always like what
sometimes you got people going to some
weird country where you're just like why
would you want to live there right
I don't know it's it's one thing if like
it's not like it's never it's never 90
days the other way and you're moving
from the United States to Paris you know
or it's like you're moving to London or
you're moving it's never that it's
usually never that it's usually like
you're going from like you know the
United States and then you're going to
like some little town in Columbia where
they don't have running water and you're
like why would you do that so it's just
that part of it's crazy but this one
before the 90 days this is like they've
talked they've met and now they're
trying to figure out if they want to do
the 90-day visa thing
and I just want to talk about how weird
these couples are you know how weird so
this is like three of the main people
three of the main couples on this one
um where is it now okay so you have this
first couple right here
um the first okay so this is the girl
first her name is Amanda 31. now Amanda
her husband tragically died and she's
got two kids she falls for this guy that
lives in like some foreign country right
and
you know this guy right here and this
guy's name is
roslan whatever his name is
um you know and I think he's a really
nice guy right he comes across as a nice
guy but there's issues like she keeps
comparing him to her dead husband and
then he's talking about well I'm an
actor and I want to go to the United
States to be an actor and she's like
well are you gonna get a job you know
because my my ex-husband was a waiter he
supported himself and then you know and
he's like well I don't want to do that
I'm trying to be an actor so it's like
and then she she keeps talking about her
ex-husband so she goes like she flies
all the way to where he lives wait where
does he live he's in Romania so she
flies to Romania and he's like trying to
smash
you coming to Romania let's get it in
and she's like I I feel like I'm
cheating on my dead husband and it's
like what like what are you talking
about
so so they're like a really weird ass
couple
and then she's kind of mean but he kind
of was fed up with it in the last
episode I saw he was like you know what
I'm done with this you know he just shut
her down you know and then now now she's
like oh actually this guy's a really
nice guy what am I doing so we'll see
what happens and she went to go meet his
family so it's just that's a weird
couple this guy I dude so this dude he
met some chick from Vietnam right and so
they're talking talking you know it's
all this texting and talking and face
timing for for years or whatever how
long it is right he don't trust her he
hires a private investigator my feeling
is this is the girl my feeling is if you
are talking with someone from long
distance and you don't trust him
to the point where you have to hire a
private investigator get out of that
relationship this ain't for you
unless
maybe we all should be doing this
unless every relationship you get into
you should hire a private investigator
that's kind of like what social media is
anyway like you know it's like when you
like when you would look at somebody's
Facebook profile or you know when you
like you meet someone you go to
Instagram and you start looking at all
their pictures you say who
is this person Facebook I believe was
better than that because people had to
put more information on Facebook you
could be like oh you went to college you
work here you've done this you've you
know you have a little bit more it's
like a little dossier but like damn if
you have to hire a private investigator
it's like I don't think that's gonna
work they are a weird ass couple and
they're always fighting
now this dude man I don't know what's up
with this dude but I believe this guy's
he might be on the Spectrum okay not
that there's anything wrong with that
I'm just saying if you don't come out
with that I look if you're autistic
even a little bit
and you just go out and you meeting
people and you got weird quirks you got
to open with I'm autistic to me because
then now I know what's up you know it
would be like if you're blind or no no
even better you're deaf let's say you're
deaf and you just go to the bar you know
and you're just like you know hey what
you know you just you just people are
like hey man you want something to drink
and you're not saying nothing you know
and then people like what's up with you
why are you acting like that and you
know you're just like it's like you got
to be like I you know I'm deaf and then
people would go oh okay they would act
accordingly they would be like all right
or they would show their true colors
that they're an [__] but it's like
you can't just be autistic and out here
in the streets and like act if you have
quirks that are not like that cause some
disruption
you gotta say something okay
this is my I don't know maybe I'm
completely off base but what I'm saying
is if you don't want to say anything
don't be surprised if people treat you a
certain way if people are like put off
by this or whatever it is I just think
they're sharing that information could
uh you find out who people are or to me
I think I think it's going to be like
give people the opportunity to be like
oh okay I'm okay with this and I give
you some Grace but anyways so this guy
he acts like he's a player and he's like
I'm always talking to people so I don't
know what his story is right he's his
Christian 30 from from front link I keep
doing this so let's keep it like this
you guys can see more as I look at the
thing right I just hated these other ads
are on there
um Chris self-proclaim life of the party
that he says right so hit all right
speaking autistic his girl
okay Cleo
she is
transgender
so that's like a whole thing and she's
this sort of introverted like how does
she describe herself
oh it's in the last the last picture
that she describes a Clio an autistic
and narrow Divergent trans woman
I don't even know what that is
Nero Divergent
okay
all right whatever is different
it's all this build up about their
relationship just dude he always talking
to other women at bars
right and then like they finally have
sex you know and then that's a whole
thing and then she got a friend
who just don't like him don't trust him
I mean it's a whole thing but it's like
they're like the weirdest couple because
you're like okay
this is one of these things where the
guy's like because I don't know if Cleo
is like fully has done everything you
know
so and he's kind of like all right me
too I I don't even know how they met
like when they met were they talking
talking and he seems to be okay with it
so it's like whatever but it's like
their interactions are so bizarre as
what I'm really trying to get at forget
the fact that she's autistic she's a
trans and he's weird you know I don't
even know if he's autistic but he's just
weird and then their interactions make
for like comedy man it's so bizarre you
gotta check that out all right this guy
oh my God David from Nebraska
uh he's deaf okay but this guy is the
sweetest guy like I'm pulling for this
guy right but he meets this [__] this
chick Sheila 31 from the Philippines let
me tell you something
appreciate everything you have man this
chick is poor okay he he went to the
Philippines to meet her and she is
living in squalor man like they
practically are living in tents it's
like it's the craziest situation and
he's so sweet he genuinely cares for her
and it's like I I'm pulling for this
couple and I'm pulling for her like he
and she's got a kid and then the kid he
don't want to move to the United States
it's like what
dude this is the one couple I'm pulling
for in this situation and then you got
this chick Misha 43 she got two fine ass
daughters you know what I mean she must
have had him when she was young they are
she's a good looking woman too they all
like it's crazy right
so she like converted she's one of these
born-again Christian types so she was
like you know she ex-ho you know what I
mean
that's basically what it is Misha a
ex-ho and then she he
she meets this 43 year old dude from
Israel so he's in Israel and he's a
Christian okay and he's a virgin
because he's like I am not gonna
they've been talking for seven years
finally met and it is the most awkward
it's sweet and awkward okay
it's it's like
so crazy their relationship and he's
it's like then you have this issue with
this age not age the the language
barrier is is always so crazy like even
with the the deaf guy with David and
this girl Sheila their relationship is
weird because she has a hearing issue
but she can still hear and talk right he
is completely deaf and they've been
talking over the phone and thing now she
he wants her hey you need to learn how
to sign because he's like talking with
his you know uh
you have to just watch it that one is
like heart wrenching sometimes it's
heartbreaking and sometimes it's very
heartwarming you know it's and he I
don't know I'm pulling for David and
then but this Misha and Nikola this
relationship is crazy man
how you a version at this age he 43
years old virgin what like what
let's just leave it at that then you
have this girl Statler from Texas and
she's a lesbian and totally into British
women that's her whole thing and she's a
little weird
um she got like some like she's so
awkward awkward as hell and then her
woman is this woman Dempsey and this
chick live out in London she don't live
in London she live out in the
countryside with no warm water like
[__]
it's
what are you talking about man it's 2023
get some warm water man I don't even I
can't stand it these kind of like
country ass people
whatever so now the girl the The Statler
girl she she
is into British women and so she like
they've been talking for a while a year
seven months whatever they're in love
she goes to visit her you know the girls
kind of kind of uncomfortable about sex
so far you know at first and then she
opens up and then so now they're like
you know having this Whirlwind romance
but once it goes she goes listen my
lease is up
I want to move in with you and that's
where they're at and it's kind of weird
y'all only known each other for seven
months and they're so different in terms
of their like one sort of introverted
and the other one's like the the girl
that's coming from the United States
she's like yeah I love sex let's have
sex in the in the open let's have sex in
a barn you know and the other one's not
like well hold on a second you know what
I mean so I don't know
and the last one is this dude another
dude who's like he might be autistic
also because he just his personality is
so quirky and like
and he's with
he's not even this guy don't even have a
lot of money right
he don't even have all the money and
this girl Jasmine they've been talking
for a while and she's like yo I want to
come to the United States you know and
he's not even rich but he's paying for
her luxury apartment in Panama and then
she live in a building with her ex her
ex live in this building too like it's
so crazy they're always fighting like
they had this big fight on the thing
where they were fighting and she was
like I know what I'm gonna go have sex
with my ex cause he is he knows how to
get me out like she's like one of those
chicks that like when they're in a fight
she goes for the jugular
I can't be with somebody like that like
if you win a fight and you say some like
you say the worst thing you could
possibly say you've been holding on to
that I don't like that that's out of
pocket but you know it also leads to
Passion but anyways
this show I'm look I didn't even know I
was gonna I didn't know I was gonna go
get into it like that
oh man but yeah somebody said things are
moving fat is not unusual for lesbian
relationships that's true you hear that
that's the stereotype of lesbian
relationships is that they move real
fast right but that one was just like I
don't know
the girls really seems to like so I do
have some new stuff that I wanted to
sort of get into uh real quick so my
Instagram stories of the week
um and then some of them are kind of
weird and like like kind of scary
actually you know so this one first one
was a retired school teacher sentenced
to death in Saudi Arabia over several
tweets
a court in Saudi sent just a 54 year old
retired teacher to death over tweets
criticized in corruption and human
rights violations
I mean you know we talk about free
speech in the United States and we talk
about how important it is and you know
of course we think the whole world
should be like this and it really isn't
it's not you know it is not and so to
have some american-based company like
Twitter or X whatever the dude's
changing it to and you know we have and
we tried to like put our values in and
our belief systems on the rest of the
world because we're sharing you know
information through this app
doesn't mean we're right not that I'm
condoning this at all I'm saying this is
terrible right and yes people should
have freedom of expression and like if
if the person is tweeting about stuff
that's real it's like yo change right
but damn you sentence people to death
for their for for saying something
man we living in strange times man you
know and then we're still waiting to
hear I don't think Elon Musk is even
like
um said anything about this yet but this
is terrible
I hope I hope that I I have to do a
follow-up story on this but this is just
some like
appreciate being in the United States
you know because there's like a there's
people that live in the United States
that just love hating on the United
States they think oh we're we're the
most racist place we're the most this
like let me tell you something right now
we're not the most racist country on
Earth we are not the most sexist country
on Earth We're not the most homophobic
country on Earth
you better wake up when people say that
I know this they've never traveled
they've never read a news article about
other places man you know like
not to say that like we're the best in
terms of like like we need to work on
our stuff but we are far ahead of a lot
of places man you know we got work to do
but I'd rather be here working on it
than any place else
crazy story
next one is I love this new law I think
that this is great and I think they
should apply this law
to it everywhere in the United States
and for more than just DUI drunk driving
so a new Texas law requires drunk
drivers to pay child support if they
kill a parent or Guardian
hell yeah
right like this seems to be like duh
I hope they do this like this is
something I think like people talk a lot
about Texas and you know if you know
it's like if you're liberal it's like
well Texas is you know Republic whatever
man forget about the left and right
politics let's just talk about what's
right and wrong
and this is one of those things I think
that is super this is this is in the
right direction like like make it a
deterrent like this is a huge deterrent
right so forget about it's almost like
this you do something horrible it's like
not even going to jail I think it's a
kind of thing you want to talk about
some work release it should be like yeah
you have to now work for the rest of
your life and and and and and and pay
for this kids you know college or
whatever too you have to you they're now
your kid you're now responsible for them
because of what you've done you know
what I mean that's a real that's a
forget prison forget like throwing
somebody away and forgetting about them
and taking you know and all the human
rights violations that go on in prison
no these put these [__] to work
that's what they need to do so I like
this
uh all of this you know yeah exactly
I know it's like see now you get like
somebody said what if you use a gun
that's a whole thing too I mean I think
it doesn't matter I'm saying if you are
the cause of the death of someone and
they have kids you yes you should now be
financially responsible for them kids
make sure that they have the best life
they can because of what you've done no
matter how you did it
that's yeah I like that
I don't know
whatever you guys say okay I know you
guys heard about this story right here
listen I've had to go to the bathroom on
the plane before
I was on a plane one time and this dude
sitting next to me
to do sit next to me so I'm like I'm
smelling something and I'm like no man
you know because you people always fart
on a plane you know you just crack one
off when you crack one off what are you
supposed to do you can't get up the seat
belt signs on you gotta fart it's just
kind of a thing where everybody on the
plane knows all right somebody farted
and you're not gonna talk about it so
I'm smelling this it's worse than a fart
I'm looking at my shoes did I step on
some stuff outside before I came into
the plane and I'm looking at this dude
and you know this dude turn on his air
and I'm like oh that's too farted
you know and then the dude gets up
and when he gets up and sort of turns
his Cannon towards towards
I realized to do [__] himself
I know he did
okay he went to the bathroom and he's
just crop dusting the whole plane
and I'm just like oh man you know when
he comes back you know I was giving them
that look like
you know
I know what you did
you know what I mean so this situation a
flight from Atlanta forced to turn
around after pilot labels passengers
diarrhea a Biohazard
dude when you have to go you have to go
but damn and I don't know any all the
stuff that's coming out we don't know if
this is true and I got this from one of
my favorite Instagram accounts I follow
puberty p-u-b-i-t-y give them a follow I
love them uh I mean you know when you
have the dude had to go and he was
probably trying to get to the bathroom
and it was spilling out his pants
they're not saying who the person is and
so then it was just diarrhea all up I
mean damn what do you do what would you
do
it's like what if it's one of the
situations where it's like they're like
okay sir please sit there you know what
if the what if the flight attendant was
doing that you can't get up right now
and it's like I gotta go to the bathroom
so what we doing
okay so I'm either gonna do it here in
my seat or you're gonna have to let me
go to the bathroom and then
he was trying to get to the bathroom and
didn't make it and so you can't clean
that up on a plane there's no like made
service you could call and then the
captain probably like the flight
attendant probably within the captain
yeah we we having a situation uh out
here and the captain's like it can't be
that bad probably opened the door and
was like
you know what I mean and then he's like
uh attention um attention everybody we
are uh we had an accident in 27 a uh and
it carried over to 4B so we are turning
this plane around
because it's like what if they what
thank God it happened when it happened
because what if they had been like this
is an eight-hour flight what if they
four hours in over the Atlantic Ocean
and the it's like oh my God and then
everybody starts throwing up it's that
it turns into Stand By Me ugh I I feel
bad for everybody on that plane I feel
bad for the person that just this
happened to and and thank goodness
they're not calling that person out
thank goodness it's not pictures of you
know shitty McGee
it isn't being like put on blast
everywhere you know so but anyways
those are the weird stories of the week
um
but let's get into something that I
wanted to uh talk about which is wait
what's going on here okay let me see
oops wait what's going on oh
I see I have to do this okay uh I'm
gonna turn this off
wait how come this isn't
I don't know why it's not
oh you know what this always doesn't
have to like go blank and then go here
there it is all right guys so finally
uh they'll close the podcast off I give
them my thoughts about the SAG after a
strike
which does affect me so sag Afters on
strike and the SEC and and some of the a
number of reasons that that they're on
strike are wage increases sag after is
Seeking a 11 wage increase retroactive
to expiration of the previous contract
in July 2022.
uh residuals sag is also seeking
improved residuals for streaming
projects
okay and and protection against
artificial intelligence AI you know
because partly they were trying to
you know use AI like let's say they take
a picture they use your likeness and
they can just put you in as an extra in
a background of a scene and then they
never have to pay you you know they you
know it's like they buy your likeness
so why do I think this is happening you
know why do I think we're on strike why
do I think this happened it's nuanced as
you know I like to say it's a nuanced
thing about uh I think that the business
has moved the business has changed and
everyone involved in it hasn't changed
with it and I think that's what the
biggest problem is
if you think back in the day let's take
a a network like NBC for instance NBC
would make a show let's say a half hour
sitcom they would make a show the show's
about 22 minutes and they gonna sell
eight minutes of ads to fill a slot from
say 8 pm to 8 30. that eight minutes of
ads so then they would use ratings to
let the advertisers know hey certain
number of people are watching this show
we know advertisement works so that's
how they were able to charge for a show
so if you had a great show
and it was like if you got a big
following you know you had a show that
got 10 million views a month then the
companies would be like whoa this is
worth
paying for ads and then you have like
you know other deals that were cut so
then for the run of the show there's
this ad money
that is coming and that pays for
everything okay it pays for Stuff
and then what would happen is a network
like TNT TBS who doesn't necessarily
make a lot of their own products they
would go well that was a hit show let me
because because what they found and this
happened way back in the day because of
I Love Lucy uh you know Rick what's his
name um you know Desi Arnez he figured
this out so Lucy was pregnant and she
was like tired so they were like you
know what just play the episode you've
already played and they were like we
can't do that and then they did it and
they got the same amount of views so
then they were like what so then that's
what became syndication so reruns okay
and I know reruns work so but if you're
selling ads for reruns well then people
should make money and that's what the
system was so then you would take a
network like TBS USA somebody's off
networks when it was just cable no
streaming yet just cable and they would
be like all right well we're gonna buy
your show too we're gonna we're gonna
license your show for like you know
however long and then actors writers
producers would still generate profit
that way because they also were selling
ads
and then they also paid for the show so
then that was how it worked we knew what
a show was getting we knew why a show
would get canceled and there was
problems with that too because you'd be
like well you know give this show a
chance to grow and then they became a
thing where yeah well we gotta cancel
that show because uh it doesn't have the
kind of views we want because it's too
expensive to make whatever it is like
that you know
um and that's and that's how that that
went about okay so cut to then you
Netflix started you know and then
Netflix was like all right well we're
gonna buy products so then they would be
like all right
um you know so this is subscriber based
Network you know so they like you know
first they were like you know they were
like it was like a DVD thing you know
they would like buy a movie or license a
movie out and then would put it on their
their thing and then but you know and
then people were making they they had
some kind of system where they were
people were making money you know but
then Netflix was like hey let's start
making our own stuff but they were still
buying stuff and I believe that
when Netflix licensed out a show let's
say a show like Workaholics
okay then Workaholics
um would go on Netflix but it was a
certain amount of time but I received
money for that it ain't a money you can
live off of but we received money for
that and by the way Workaholics is a
good example of networks going oh wait a
minute this is our product we're just
going to own it and then so like this
will have more Comedy Central so that
Comedy Central had Workaholics and then
they didn't sell it to another Network
they were like nah this is our show
we're gonna keep it here we're gonna
people are watching it we'll just keep
it on we'll just keep airing it on our
Network oh it's coming on again well
that wasn't necessarily great for the
actors based off the old system like we
would have wanted that to go to 100
episodes and then sell it to TNT and now
Workaholics is on TNT and then we're
making money they didn't do that
networks were like well why should we do
that this is our show right so they cut
to net now Netflix is like this they
said we're gonna make our own shows
we're gonna produce our shows and we're
gonna own them
that's the issue right there
and they started doing buyouts even in
the commercial world I've done many
commercials
so if you do a commercial
you used to be able to make a lot of
residuals if it was played on a network
show the actors in those commercials
would make money it used to be you could
buy a house with those residuals sag
messed up a long time ago by not you
know cutting a better deal for digital
and cutting a better deal for commercial
work that's a whole other issue and
that's also a part of the problem we're
having now sag sucks okay they that that
they they were so arrogant about film
you know that they should have taken on
digital they didn't realize this
technology was going to take over but
anyways whole other issue
so then you would have a buyout so let's
say I do a car commercial right so if I
did a car commercial they would go
here's a buyout we'll pay you 10 grand
for to be in this commercial and it's
gonna air for a year but here's the
thing
if they aired the commercial past a year
they would have to pay you again
that's how that worked it wasn't in
perpetuity that's what's wrong with
Netflix I'm just using them as an
example so Netflix is like this we're
gonna pay you to make the show we're
gonna pay you a buyout but then they
keep the show on the the platform for as
long as they want because they own it so
now we're sitting around being like well
wait a minute that's not how we used to
do it but the business has changed
that's the issue
and Netflix is a damn Ponzi scheme
really
they got
Netflix has I looked this up all right
they have
238.39 million paid subscribers
worldwide let's just say conservatively
everybody's paying an average of ten
dollars a month for Netflix that's
2 billion dollars a month
so
and they have to provide a service and
that Services content 24 hours a day
so now
the actors Union is like well wait a
minute
but all the producers and actors and
everyone agreed to take the buyouts I'll
do your show it's 50 Grand an episode
sometimes they overpay sometimes they
pay more than other networks would pay
because they know there's going to be no
residuals because they're like all right
we're gonna buy we're gonna create your
show a sitcom some of these shows and
sitcoms they're like five to eight
million dollars an episode to make so
they're going we'll make 10 episodes
we're gonna front the bill we're gonna
pay 80 million dollars to make this show
for 10 season 10 episodes and we own it
it's ours and we're gonna put it on our
platform okay
now we're starting to see like well wait
a minute it's still on there
and we only got paid once but that's the
business that's the you know
we now we have to just completely change
the business so now it's like gonna be a
thing where Netflix is gonna be like all
right
okay so all right well we're going to
we're only gonna keep your show on for
three years and then we have to take it
off well then what what are they gonna
do with it then nobody sees it
you know I just don't know that's the
Nuance of it it's gonna be so hard to
like figure this out so then it's gonna
be like Netflix will be like okay well
then that we'll sell it to another
company or like they have to figure out
some algorithm of like all right this is
oh you get if your show continues to get
this many views you're going to get this
amount of money of the subscription
money like they have to figure something
out but the main issue is they shouldn't
have done it like that we shouldn't have
said like all right in perpetuity you
own the show and then uh that's it we
you know you could keep it on the air
for as long as you want the fact that's
what it is now I can tell you this right
now Netflix is going to an ad based
system they're gonna get like they're
gonna have ads and they'll be like a
cheaper price to get it and then you
have to see watch ads or movies and
stuff like that once that system starts
they'll probably pay proper residuals
okay
um you know because then the ad
companies will be like okay we want ads
on Wednesday for instance you know it
got 30 million views you know and it's
still being watched then they'll be like
like all right uh people be like we want
we want ads on that show well however
that system is going to work that's
going to have to come into place and
then we'll see what happens but for now
the business has changed and we haven't
changed with it and then these other
companies are going like this now so now
now NBC they're going to be like this
okay we're gonna make a show all right
we own it it's our show then we're gonna
throw it on our streaming platform
peacock you know and then we're gonna
make this is what always used to Boggle
my mind you would pay for cable so now
I'm paying monthly for cable
and I'm watching commercials
listen to that you are paying for cable
and watching commercials
what
and they're gonna ask you to pay for the
streaming service to watch the show that
you've already seen on the other thing
crazy
uh
this is all about greed
but it's never going to go the way the
actors want the actors and writers we're
never going to get what we want out of
this
and right now this is a big issue
a company like Netflix for say they
don't have to stop
they don't have to agree to anything
they're just going to be like okay stay
on strike Netflix is gonna be like this
stay on strike for as long as you want
because guess what
when there's no new shows on NBC CBS ABC
USA when all the new shows aren't being
re-upped when they're not being made
right now
guess where people are going to go to
watch entertainment
and that's what's happening right now
while no shows and movies are being made
people are on Netflix
and guess what no one's canceling their
subscription subscription
if people cared about actors and writers
and all that they would be like I'm
canceling my subscription until you pay
them properly are people doing that no
if 20 million people said we are no
longer we're we're I am I am putting my
subscription on hold until you pay these
actors and writers
should it be done like this
but that's not what's happening in fact
they're probably getting more
subscribers now the people that are
being hurt are places like Warner
Brothers because I heard this Warner
Brothers Discovery says it will take 300
million to 500 million hit in 2023
earnings due to due to the stack strike
because
those the networks who are still on an
old business model they're like hey
we have to provide content for our
advertisers
the streaming people are like we don't
have to do that
we own these shows so now the only way
to me moving forward that this is going
to work is if you're a production
company or you're a creator of content
with Netflix your deal has to be I need
to get this amount of money
and you can only keep my product on your
network for three years and if and or
whatever long you're we're paying for
this
and once that's done
I own my show back and I can sell it to
wherever I want
or or I don't know but it has to be
something like that
and these other streaming services they
don't work Paramount plus is
hemorrhaging money because nobody wants
Paramount Plus
okay like not not 200 million people
where it's profitable
and then they're like okay what are we
going to do what Netflix is doing we're
gonna have we're gonna have all these
subscribers and all this money that's
going to come in we're going to make
movies with that money no it doesn't
work like that y'all should have sold
your stuff to Netflix everybody was
trying to be Netflix and Netflix they're
one of a kind they got to the market
first and they won everyone else needs
to just get on board
you know the only other one that's like
working like that is companies that have
money from other Revenue sources like
apple and Amazon Amazon got
refrigerator money they don't care about
they don't care about actors and and all
that stuff because
they're getting their money from Prime
it's just an add-on it's just an add-on
they're like hey and that's what Apple
does Apple has this thing so for 29 a
month you get the news so you can you
get all like Rolling Stone variety L.A
times Washington Post you get all that
you get uh uh
um what is it called you can save
storage for your phone you know you get
storage for your phone so two terabytes
of storage for your phone and you get
Apple TV
so they don't care they get they got
phone money they got Apple money and
people are paying this Apple TV and
whatnot because then they're like okay
great and here's the thing too Apple's
not dumb
they don't just let you binge and that's
the thing I guarantee you and I said
this on my Rogan episode like seven
years ago Netflix is gonna move to the
they're not gonna they're not gonna
binge anymore there's too many products
on Netflix
so then that's how they'll be able to
share more revenue is by not having so
many products on at once so it should be
like this stranger things if there's 10
episodes it should take 10 weeks to
watch it
and then you can watch it you know binge
after that and then you won't have to
have as many products on the air when
you put the whole thing on and then in
three weeks people are done they're like
okay uh what's next I need to see more
that binging shit's gonna go away
because that's the only way they need to
have less products and then this Revenue
that's not gonna go away because here's
the thing they still gonna be making the
two billion dollars a month
now they'll have more of that two
billion dollars instead of having to
worry about creating new products they
get they can have more quality instead
of quantity and then pay paid producers
and actors and writers more money that's
what I think
there's more to it than that but that's
just my initial thoughts on it right now
I'm gonna keep talking about this more
I'm gonna get more educated on what's
going on
but that's just where I see
the the initial problem right now is
that the business has changed and
neither side has changed with it you
know but the networks they're still an
old model because they're still selling
ads they're still getting spectral money
and all the money they get from the
cable networks and stuff so they have
the money to be like all right if our
show's going to be on the air we're
going to pay our actors but like
independent filmmakers and all these
kind of people they want
they want shows
they you know like you're doing an
independent film you want people to
watch your film people aren't
necessarily going to theaters to watch
Independent films so you know where they
have to go they got to go to streaming
places so it's like that's like you know
that's that's a whole that's a whole
issue that you know we're gonna figure
out but anyways guys I want to thank
everybody for watching riffin with
Griffin stay tuned for more coming up
and we will keep you posted on that but
as you know you know how we do
here on river with Griffin
with that rap recap
make sure you subscribe
[Music]
subscribe
a lot and all that giant
come to Twitch Watch Me game
doing it for the bang
everybody know my name
is bomb
[Music]
whatever
rap recap
step up and get slapped
you know it ain't right
it's got a bite
there's no end in sight
I'm not making right
like flying a kite
[Music]
my rap style slang
you know I don't play
kicking the ball like Pele
the other way
I'm glad you stayed
all right y'all thanks for watching
riffing with Griffin
stay tuned for more sag after news in
the coming weeks if you have a crazy
story you saw on the internet and you
want me to talk about it send it to me
on Instagram or email me at
ericgriffin.com but go to my Instagram
you can just send me like a little link
like yo grip look at this crazy thing
you got a show you want me to talk about
anything like that I will but anyways
guys thanks for watching we're filming
with Griffin and I'll see you next week
oh
[Music]